it's great to see you here tonight at
the premiere of the quiet ones what was
your favorite moment in the movie I love
the bit where I have a fight with Aaron
and then stick my hands down some puns
it was like not sticking the hand down
the pants I was really awkward but just
the fire literally I was the adrenaline
was just coursing through men I came
away with so many bruises on my own I
was like oh my god I've done such a good
job and what was it like stepping into
that world of Hammer horror movie it was
amazing it cheap
someone Oh Simon Oakes wrote in my
leather bound book of the quiet ones
you're the next Hara hammer heroin and I
was just like that is so iconic it's
just it's absolutely incredible
it is crazy like to be here and it's
Hammer horror like it's so prolific and
what was it like working with Sam as
well oh he's lovely so charming he's
such a good actor in it
and he does you can definitely see
on-screen and he's very conscientious to
the crew and the and to me come into it
a teen or first film I definitely looked
up to him and Jared well you were
horrifying yourself what kind of horror
movies do you like what what makes you
scared I love a love I love her
paranormal one schedule Living Daylights
on me I hated it oh my god I thought it
was real so for three weeks I didn't
sleep insidious I loved all of the sort
of just a theater of it and well it's
woman in black I love
it's one in black - yeah I'm really
intrigued what what - what they do with
it I've not heard anything you think I
would but I'm not now of course we know
we love you as well in Bates Motel which
is been doing brilliantly hasn't it
I mean how likely do you think we are
see a season three for now because had
to crack in season so far
oh I think really likely that if the
fans want it and if it still if it keeps
on getting funds and growing bigger than
of course it's going to get a season
through without dough what's been the
most enjoyable part being part of that
world for you working with Vera Farmiga
she is a force
I've never been to drama school so
watching her was just like a looking for
a lesson in itself she's amazing she's
amazing she's everything that I want to
be and more where'd you like to see them
take Emma and Norman in future I think
it's safe to say that I think it'll
takes something to happen to Emma for
Norman to really realize his feelings
for her and he does it's just very
embedded somewhere in your line is
groton heart so I'll have to see him I
think one of those things so it's scary
to kind of get the script I think my god
book cuz there happen next
yeah because we get we get the in
Episode two weeks in advance before we
shoot it so we're literally like okay so
you can give us any any tips on Episode
six is what's gonna happen then am I
gonna you don't know okay
Emma's okay brilliant we're gonna let
the boy see lots Morgan that and a show
people gonna live the quiet ones as well
thankfully oh thank you so much
you